[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]
BRENNAN SAETA: Hi,
my name is Brennan.
I'm an engineer on the
Brain Team at Google.
And I work on cloud TPUs.
So that's what we're
going to talk about today.
So to begin with, I wanted
to start with a little bit
of motivation.
Why?
Why TPUs?
What are we here?
This is a chart that I'm
actually really quite fond of.
It was recently published
by Open AI on their AI blog.
And it traces over
the last six years
a number of seminal
advancements that have happened
in the field of deep learning.
You can see on the
left AlexNet, which
is one of the ones
that the models
that really kicked off the deep
learning revolution that we're
experiencing today.
As you go farther
together the right,
you can see more
advanced vision models.
But you also see whole new
capabilities being unlocked.
Translation, deep speech
with audio processing,
neural machine translation,
Dota 1v1 real-time game playing,
and one of my
favorites, AlphaGo Zero,
and Alpha Zero at the top right.
And as deep learning
has progressed,
we've gotten more and
more stuff that we're
able to do with deep learning,
which is really cool.
But if you notice the
y-axis of the plot,
we need not just linearly
increasing amount of compute,
we need exponentially
more compute.
Unfortunately, just as we
need exponentially more
compute to do deep
learning and unlock
this world of possibilities,
Moore's Law, or in particular
we're running into the
end of Dennard scaling.
Single core clock performance
is not improving very much.
Single thread performance IPC
has basically hit a brick wall.
Even though we're
still increasing
the number of
transistors, that trend
is even starting to
slow down more recently.
And so we're really in between
a rock and a hard place.
And so we at Google, we
realized that deep learning
was so important.
And we realized that it was
so broadly applicable that we
started investing in custom
accelerators all the way back
in--
even before 2015.
So in the top left-hand corner
is our first generation TPU.
There are actually
these actual devices
available in the booth over
there if you're here in person.
Our first generation
TPU was designed
just for inference
only, so serving a model
after it's been trained.
This was very
important as we were
deploying our first, large-scale
deep learning models at Google.
But over time, we realized that
training was just incredibly
hard to do and to do it well.
And so we started investing
in our second generation
TPU, which you see
in the middle here.
But we realized that
in order to train
bigger, more powerful
models, we need
to have these TPUs
all linked together
and focus on a single task in
a very tightly coupled fashion.
And so these TPU
devices are really
designed to be deployed in
TPU pods, which you can see
on our top right-hand corner.
But deep learning is
advancing so rapidly,
and there's so much
possibilities for this field.
We've been iterating
extremely quickly.
And at the bottom, our
third-generation TPU pod
is over eight times faster
and is available just less
than a year after our
second generation TPU pod.
So we're really excited about
all that we can do with TPUs.
And we're excited to bring them
to you as part of cloud TPUs.
So that's our motivation
for why we're here.
This is what I'm going to
be talking about today.
The first is the life
of a TPU program.
Let's dig into what
actually happens
underneath the hood when
you're running on a cloud TPU.
The second part is what do you
want to do, how do you actually
program these TPU devices.
And the third part, we'll spend
a few minutes talking about one
of the most common
stumbling blocks
that people run into
when they're first
using TPUs, which is how to
keep them fed fast enough.
They're just so fast.
It really is an interesting
engineering challenge
to feed data.
So with no further ado,
let's dig right in.
So if you want to run a
program on a cloud TPU,
well, you've got to provision
your cloud TPU resources.
And so let's talk a
little bit about that.
We show this picture of like
one cloud TPU device, right?
This is our
second-generation TPU device.
But really you never
see them bare like this
in our data center.
These are specialized devices.
And they're not
general purpose, right?
They're optimized just
for machine learning.
So in practice, we
deploy them often
in what we call these
pod configurations.
So here you've got two
middle racks of TPUs.
You actually have an 8-by-8
or 64 total cloud TPU
devices hooked together in
this custom mesh network.
And flanking these 64
TPU devices are actually
64 general purpose x86
machines in racks a and d.
And their job is to feed
and manage the TPU core.
When you request
one cloud TPU, you
don't get just the
TPU device itself.
You also get the dedicated
server for that TPU device.
So one cloud TPU is actually
two pieces of hardware,
often in two separate racks.
OK, so that's what the
physical hardware is.
How does this look like from
a cloud platform perspective?
I'm going to talk about
TPUs on Compute Engine,
but this applies for the other
higher-level products, which
we'll talk about
later in the talk.
But if you have a bunch of
Compute Engine VMs running
in your private network,
if you're like me
you'll often store your data
in Google Cloud Storage,
in a storage bucket.
This means it's available
to multiple GCVMs.
It's really cheap,
really scalable.
And when you want to allocate
a cloud TPU, what happens
is you get the dedicated
cloud TPU host and TPU device.
And in order to access
them, we open up
this network peering
channel, or this bridge.
And once that's open,
you can actually
connect to it from your GCEVMs
over TensorFlow's open source
GRPC protocol.
Now in this picture, I'm showing
one Compute Engine VM talking
to one cloud TPU, but this is
designed for maximum control
and flexibility.
So you can have multiple VMs
talking to one cloud TPU.
You can have one VM controlling
multiple cloud TPUs,
or any combination you want.
Cool.
So how do you make that happen?
Well, it's just a couple
of G Cloud commands away.
gcloud compute instances
create to create your GCVM.
gcloud compute tpus
create to create your TPU.
SSH in your VM,
install TensorFlow,
and you're off to the races.
Well, not quite so fast.
These are sort of
complicated commands.
Let's break it
down a little bit.
When you create a
cloud TPU, you need
to specify the version
of TensorFlow installed.
And the reason for that is
because TensorFlow is not
designed to work across
different versions.
If you're running a distributed
TensorFlow cluster where
one node is running
TensorFlow 1.8 and one node
is running TensorFlow
1.9, you're
going to have a really bad day.
The errors are absolutely
unintelligible.
So when you create
a cloud TPU, you
need to specify what version
of TensorFlow you want to use.
Additionally, you
have to specify
what network address range you
want to give over to the TPU
so that the TPU can be
peered onto your network.
And so you can see
the list of routes.
Pick a route that is
unoccupied, and go for that.
Now this is sort of involved
and requires too much thinking.
And so because I create
a lot of cloud TPUs
as part of using them, I
created a tool called ctpu.
Now ctpu is short for the
cloud TPU provisioning utility.
And if you just run ctpu
up, it will basically
set everything up for you.
Launch a GCVM with
TensorFlow pre-installed,
create your cloud TPU, make sure
it's peered up appropriately,
and it'll even SSH you into your
GCVM, get you all ready to go.
One thing to note. ctpu up
is designed to be idempotent.
So if you have like a
GCVM already running
and your preemptible
cloud TPU got preempted,
you want to get things
back into a working state,
just rerun ctpu up.
It'll SSH you back in.
Cool.
So now that we have the
cloud resources, let's
actually run something
on our cloud TPU, right?
The whole point of this.
I would be remiss if
I did not emphasize
the availability of
our reference models
for cloud TPUs.
They span a wide variety
of vertical domains.
They are tested.
They work really well.
Some of them are even commented.
It's really nice.
They are available
on open source
on GitHub and on
our cloud TPU VMs.
If you provision a
VM with ctpu, they're
available on the file
system at user share TPU.
But this is the TensorFlow
cloud TPU deep dive.
So we're going to ignore
these big fancy scripts,
and we're going to go down
to the basest, barest level.
And so we're going
to ignore those
for the rest of this talk.
TensorFlow underneath its
hood is a distributed graph
execution engine.
You build up a computational
graph, often with Python.
You pass it to the core
TensorFlow distributed runtime.
And you then execute that graph.
So here we have a graph for
a two-layer neural network.
And you can see the
graph executing.
And so what we're
going to do is we're
going to build a simple graph
and execute it on a TPU.
So this is a
technical deep dive,
so we're going to see
a lot of code today.
Here is a very
simple implementation
of a linear aggressor
using TensorFlow.
So we first describe
our stateful nodes
in our graph, our
variables w and b.
These are the values
we want to learn.
We then take as input x and y.
These are our training data
and our training labels.
We compute our predicted values,
y p with a matrix multiply,
because x and y are
batches of training values.
We compute the loss by
doing the squared error.
And we want to
minimize the loss,
so we want to take
advantage of TensorFlow's
automatic differentiation and
gradient update capabilities
with our optimizer.
We're using Atom, which is
a variation on a momentum
optimizer, highly recommended.
So this is a linear aggressor
in low-level TensorFlow.
How do you make
it work on a TPU?
Well as it turns out,
you don't change anything
about your model.
You keep that all the same.
But what you need
to do is you need
to tell TensorFlow hey, this
part, make this go on the TPU.
And so to do that you pass your
model function, the part that
describes your model that
you want to run on the TPU,
you pass that to this
tf contrib TPU rewrite.
And what this will do is
this will tell TensorFlow
put this part of the
computational graph
that I'm building onto the TPU.
Once you've done
that, you've now
built a TensorFlow graph that
is set up to run on a TPU.
So now let's actually run it.
To run a computational
graph in TensorFlow,
you've got to create
a TensorFlow session.
But you can't pass the TPU
name to the TensorFlow session
constructor.
It doesn't know how to--
standard, open-source
TensorFlow doesn't know anything
about cloud TPUs.
So how do you make this work?
Well, we have this
thing in TensorFlow
called cluster resolvers.
So we have a TPU
cluster resolver
where you pass that, the
name of your cloud TPU.
It will, on your behalf,
contact the cloud TPU API,
figure out all the metadata
about your cloud TPU,
and take care of all the
underlying details for you.
So to create a TensorFlow
session on a cloud TPU,
you just create the
cluster resolver
and you pass that to
your session constructor.
One thing to note.
If you are using ctpu
or you're running
on Kubernetes Engine
or other environments,
the TPU closer resolver
is clever enough
to inspect your
environment to figure out
what your TPU name probably is.
And so you can pass none, and
it will try and figure out
what actually should be there.
So this is really
convenient if you're
sharing scripts across
multiple people,
or sharing multiple cloud TPUs.
Cool.
So now that we have the session,
it's really straightforward
to actually run our
program on the cloud TPU.
So here we're doing
random variables,
because this is a toy example.
We initialize the TPU
system, and then we're
sort of off to the races.
Now one thing to note.
This TPU initialized system
is relatively heavyweight.
So it's going to clear the
entire TPU system state,
interrupts any
running TPU programs
that are running
on the TPU devices,
rebuilds the mesh network, and
gets everything ready and clean
for you to use.
After that, here we're going to
run 100 steps of our training
loop, print out the losses,
and shut down the system.
So if you were to paste all
this into fu.py and type Python
fu.py enter, you'll
see your cursor blink
for like 10 or 15 seconds.
And then 100 lines of
loss will be printed out.
So those 10 or 15
seconds, that's
initializing the TPU system.
We're working on making
that go a little bit faster.
But then after that,
the computation
runs really quickly.
OK, so we just talked
about how we programmed it
from a low-level standpoint,
but what actually
happened inside the cloud TPU?
Cloud TPUs, the TPU chips,
they're not x86 chips.
You can't run a standard
program that you get out
of GCC or Clang.
And so in order to run a
program on a cloud TPU,
you need to have a compiler.
And we use the XLA compiler.
So what is XLA?
XLA stands for Accelerated
Linear Algebra.
And it's this custom,
domain-specific compiler that
takes in high-level,
pure functional programs
in a language called HLO And
it outputs optimized binary
programs for either
CPUs, GPUs, or TPUs.
Now XLA, it has a
few restrictions.
It's a linear, high-level
linear algebra-based language.
You've got matrix multiplies,
convolutions, broadcast,
reduce some ops,
et cetera, but you
don't have very branchy
things like jpeg
de-code or other sorts
of low-level operations.
Additionally, you have to--
we require static shapes.
But in exchange for
these restrictions,
we give you a few super powers.
The first one is
operation fusion.
Now operation fusion I think is
best illustrated in an example.
If you're trying to write a
program to some three very
large matrices, but
your matrix library only
has support for summing
two matrices together,
well, you can work around
that by doing a plus b
and write that to
a temporary value.
And then do temporary plus c
and get your eventual value.
And you can do that, but
it's a performance cost.
You've got to read and
write this temporary value.
And it ends up being a very
significant performance cost.
XLA, because it sees
your whole program
and it optimizes
everything, it can actually
give you the optimal program
without having you specify it.
So that's one XLA super power.
And what this gives
you is this means
you can write your own
composite operations.
You aren't stuck into restricted
kernels that only work well
for certain hardware devices.
You can invent
your own primitives
that then get compiled to
high-performance programs that
run on the TPU.
Additionally, because XLA is
a whole program optimizer,
and it's in this pure
functional language,
this means we can
actually not just optimize
the instructions that get
executed on your processor,
but this means we can optimize
the memory layouts as well.
So I think this
most often comes up
if you're doing convolutional
networks on GPUs today.
The recommendation was to do
what's called channels first
for most GPUs.
You got much better performance
if you did NCHW right?
Batch channels height, width.
But actually on the latest
Volta's with their tensor
cores, you get far
better performance
if you go back to the standard
TensorFlow image format, which
is channels last NHWC.
With XLA, you never
have to worry about
what is your memory shape
formats or whatever.
It will pick the optimal
format for your hardware
based on what program
you're trying to do,
compile your program
just for you.
The final thing that XLA
does is it does software
pipelining really, really well.
And we'll see why that's
important a little bit later.
So fine, XLA is great, cool.
What does it matter to me?
I'm a TensorFlow
programmer, right?
I don't want to
write XLA programs.
Well, that's why we have
what's called the TensorFlow
to XLA bridge.
And what this will do is this
will take a TensorFlow graph
and this will convert
some part of your graph
to be an XLA program.
So how this works is we've
got these TF to XLA kernels.
So you've marked out in the
rewrite for TPU function.
You've marked out a subset
of your TensorFlow graph
to run on the TPU.
So what we'll do is
we'll go through op by op
and translate them into
portions of the XLA program.
Here are the XLA graph
on the right-hand side.
For add, it's a straightforward
one-to-one mapping.
But for softmax, there is no
softmax, what's called HLO, op.
And so instead the kernel
builds up the softmax operation
from the set of primitives.
What this means is
that if you want
to write your own operation
that's different than softmax,
you can build it up
from your own primitives
and it will run just
as fast as softmax
modular, the performance
characteristics
of your computation, right?
There's nothing special.
Once we finish translating
the whole program into the XLA
graph, the TensorFlow runtime
will execute the XLA compiler
on the XLA program
that it built up
for you, replace that
subset of your graph
with this custom XLA
program, and then it
will run the graph
just like you'd expect.
OK, so that tells us what
bits of software are involved.
But like, let's dig
one level deeper.
What actually happened
on the TPU chips?
In order to understand
that, we need
to understand what
are the TPU chips.
We need to see what's
going on with them.
So one TPU chip,
this is a V2 chip.
The V3 chip has double
the amount of HBM
and is little bit
faster in the core.
But in a V2 chip,
you've got two cores.
Each core is identical.
So let's double click
on one of the cores
and see what's going on.
You've got three key components.
You've got the
scalar unit, you've
got the vector unit,
and the matrix unit.
So the scalar unit,
that's typically
used for loop
indexing, making sure
if you're doing a
loop n times you
do it n times, computing
addresses and memory, things
like that.
The vector unit is
very sophisticated.
It has support for float 32.
This is IEEE float32, int32,
this funky format, bfloat16,
which we'll hear
about in a minute.
Through software it
can support a lot
of other formats like int64,
complex 64, et cetera,
where you've got an int32
real part, an int32 imaginary,
et cetera.
And it lets you do
all sorts of things,
compute transcendentals,
things like that.
But the real heart of the
cloud TPU is the matrix unit.
So this is a special
hardware circuit
design called a systolic array.
And so the matrix unit is a
128 by 128 matrix multiply
systolic array.
And it is optimized
for machine learning.
It takes in as input bfloat16,
or float32 values, computes
the multiplication in
this format bfloat16,
sums up the values in
float32, and the output
is then in float32.
So for those of you who
need a bit of a refresher
course on IEEE
floating point formats,
I know I certainly did, here's
my brief handy dandy guide.
So IEEE defined what's
called single precision
floating point format.
And this uses 32 bits and
is often called FP 32.
You've got one sign bit.
You've got 8 bits of exponents.
And then the rest
of the 32 bits,
so you've got 23
bits left, that's
the mantissa or the significant.
And that's sort of like
how precise of a number
you're able to specify.
Now IEEE also defined
a 16-bit half precision
floating point format.
And this is sort of the very
natural extension from FP 32.
You take a few bits
away from the exponent,
you take a few bits
away from the mantissa.
Bada bing bada boom, you've got
16-bit floating point format.
One thing to note, however,
is that the range ends up
being quite drastically reduced.
And when you train
neural networks,
you'll find that if you
want to use float16,
and there are a
lot of good reasons
why you want to use a 16-bit
floating point format,
you have to do a
bunch of clever tricks
in order to make sure
it keeps training.
If you-- most times when you
train a neural network in FP 16
without any modifications, your
losses will explode to infinity
or you'll get not a
number, NaNs, or your model
just won't train.
You'll have vanishing
gradients that go down to zero.
And this is because
neural networks really
need a large range in order
to often train effectively.
And we recognize this
at Google, because we
train a lot of neural networks.
And so we did a bunch of
studies across a broad range
of neural networks,
and we realized
that if you have a different
floating point format,
this can often be a
drop-in replacement.
So we invented, on
the Google Brain
team, the bfloat16 format.
This is short for brain floating
point format in 16 bits.
And this preserves the
exact same range of FP 32,
but does it in 16 bits.
And as it turns out, this is
often a drop-in replacement
for FP 32.
But because it's only in 16
bits, it takes half the space.
That means your memory
feels twice as large.
This means that your memory
bandwidth is twice as fast.
So it's a really cool
performance optimization
that we've done in TPUs.
Cool.
So now that we know about
floating point formats,
let's talk a bit more about
the matrix multiply unit.
This is a 128 by 128
matrix multiply unit.
So does that mean
that my model has
to be composed entirely of
128 by 128 matrix multiplies?
Well, the answer is no.
So here's a study on RestNet-50.
And I took a single cloud TPU
device that you can run today
and I basically sweeped a
number of different batch sizes.
And this is per core batch size.
So remember, a TPU
device has eight cores.
So this is our per
core batch size.
As you go from one
to eight, you'll
see performance is increasing
very significantly.
We reach our peak performance
at batch size 128.
So what's going on here?
The XLA compiler
is able to realize
that if your batch
size is 128, that
fits really nicely with the 128
by 128 matrix multiply unit.
But to really understand
what's going on,
I think it's easiest if we
plot it on a log scale, right?
We're doubling the
per core batch size
on the y ax-- on the x-axis.
So let's turn the y-axis also
into a logarithmic scale.
And here it's little
bit easier to see.
We've got two distinct trends.
It's a piecewise
performance layer.
We increase performance
practically linearly from batch
size one to batch size 8.
But after that, performance
improves only a little bit.
What this means is that XLA is
able to do a really good job
software pipelining all the
optimizations after you get
to batch size 8 on a cloud TPU.
Now this is just on RestNet-50.
There have been a
variety of other models
that work really, really well
at even smaller batch sizes,
depending upon
whatever things are.
So one question we
often get is do I
need to have my model
be batch size 120,
or do you need to have my
model be like 128 everywhere?
The answer is, of course, no.
XLA takes care of getting
you the optimal code
generation across a variety of
different model architectures
and batch sizes.
OK, so now that we know a
little bit about the chip, now
we can really delve
down and figure out
what actually happened in
our linear aggressive program
on a TPU.
So the first step, if
you load the weights
into our matrix multiply
unit, after that we stream
through our training
data into the matrix
multiply unit, compute
the matrix multiply,
and stream the output out.
Now I mentioned about
Operation Fusion.
XLA is actually able to, in
parallel, stream the values
into the vector unit, compute
the loss or the activations
or whatever other operations
your model requests,
and stream those
values out in parallel.
And as a result, you get
really high performance,
and you're really able
to take advantage of all
the capabilities on the chip.
So we've been delving really
deep into one single program,
but as it turns
out all we've been
doing is running on a single
core of our cloud TPU device.
TPUs are designed to
be networked together.
And they're designed
to be parallel devices.
So multi-core execution
is very important.
As it turns out, because we
have this custom networking,
because we've designed
these things from the ground
up for parallel compute,
it's actually really easy
to make these go, not just on
a single core, but across cores
up to a whole pod.
All you need to do is you
need to take your optimizer
and wrap it in this TPU
cross shard optimizer.
What this means is this
coordinates the optimization
routines that are
being run on your model
across all the different
compute cores in a TPU device
all the way up to
a whole TPU pod.
After that, you just say batch
parallel instead of rewrite.
So this is a higher-level API.
Specify the number
of shards, and done.
You're off to the races.
That is all you need to do.
So we've been walking through
how to write a TPU program.
We've been using
low-level TensorFlow.
This is because we
wanted to see what's
going on underneath the hood.
But really no one writes
low-level TensorFlow on TPUs.
It is too verbose.
The low-level APIs we're
optimizing and changing
relatively frequently,
it means you're
locked into a TPU program.
There's a lot of features
and performance optimizations
that are also very hard to
write in low-level TensorFlow.
So how do we program TPUs?
The first thing I want to tell
you about is TPU estimator.
So TensorFlow is designed
to go across a wide variety
of platforms that go from
research to production.
And many of our
production users have
realized that many
of their problems
can be decomposed
into two key aspects.
The first aspect is
describing your machine
learning model,
this random forest,
a convolutional neural
network, a deep neural network.
And these models are often
generic across the input data.
So you write a
second input function
that describes what data
you want to load in.
And by decomposing this into
these two distinct parts,
you then pass these functions
to their core estimator logic,
and the estimator takes care
of all the nitty gritty things
like handling failures,
checkpointing,
exporting for inference, a
whole bunch of other really
nice things.
And so the TensorFlow
estimator API
is used by a vast majority of
production teams at Google.
And so we wanted to make it
really easy to take your model
and go from estimators
to TPU estimators
whether you're running on
CPUs and GPUs before or TPUs.
So here's a code sample of
actually a full-working,
estimator-based model.
So I've sort of
masked out the bottom.
On the top, this
is identical code
if you're running with standard
estimators or TPU estimators.
At the top of the
model function,
we describe our
deep neural network.
We have our optimizer.
On the right-hand side we've
got our input function.
So we're loading data
from a path on disk.
We're parsing out
our TF record values
and returning a data set
that has the training
data we want to train on.
The only changes are
in the bottom half.
And aside from a few
mechanical changes,
changing standard
estimator to TPU estimator
and standard estimator
spec to TPU estimator spec,
there's only two small changes.
[COUGHS]
Excuse me.
The first one is, as
we saw before, you'll
want to run across multiple
cores on a TPU device.
Your TPU device is way faster
when they all work together.
So you've got to use that
cross shard optimizer.
The only other thing is to
pass the TPU cluster resolver
that we saw before so the
estimator knows how to find
your TPU on the network.
That's it.
It's really easy to go
from an estimator that
runs on CPUs or GPUs to an
estimator-- to a TPU estimator
that will run on TPUs all the
way up to a whole TPU pod.
But I want to actually
call out one thing.
We on the TensorFlow
team, we want
to go wherever you want to
go for your machine learning
workloads.
This means CPUs, this means
GPUs, and this means TPUs.
And so we've worked very hard
so that if you just pass,
use TPU as equal to false
to a TPU estimator model,
you will get identical behavior
to standard estimators that run
on all your other platforms.
So once you migrate
to TPU estimator,
it is very easy to run
on any platform you want,
CPUs, GPUs, or TPUs.
Let's dig one level
deeper and give you
a bit of intuition
about this abstraction.
The model function is
what runs on the TPU.
This gets compiled by XLA
and goes really, really fast.
The input function
runs on the x86 CPU
hosts that are attached.
And now that you know sort
of a little bit of intuition
about what's going
on, you can start
doing funny optimizations.
Say, for example, you have
some input preprocessing that
logically belongs in
the input function,
but it's super
computationally expensive
and the CPUs just can't keep up.
Well, you can put that at the
top of your model function
and have that compiled
and run on the TPU.
And as long as it
compiles from the TPU,
can get all the
performance advantages
of running on the
accelerator device.
By contrast, if
you have something
that can't compile
for the TPU, go ahead
and hoist that into
your input function
with one key restriction.
If you need to take
the gradient of it,
that has to happen in
the model function.
It does have to go under
the TPU because that's
the way we do the cross shard
coordination is on the TPU
device itself.
We totally keep the
CPUs out of the path
because that's how we get the
amazing performance that we
see on TPUs.
TPU estimator is designed
for production reliability,
scalability, and performance.
It automatically
handles failures.
So it does automatically saving
checkpoints and restoring
from the checkpoints.
It has a very stable API that
doesn't change very much, even
though it still is in contrib.
There is very
little boilerplate.
You just define your model
and your input function,
and construct your estimator,
you're off to the races.
But we've heard
from a lot of folks
that although they really
liked TPU estimator,
we've heard some other folks
that they don't quite like it.
They want a little
bit more flexibility.
bit more control.
And so I'm really excited
to announce to you today
that Keras on cloud TPUs will
be available on TensorFlow 110.
Our release candidates
for TF 110 just got--
first-release candidates
dropped just yesterday.
But we're really
excited about what this
brings to our cloud TPU users.
So let's talk about how this
Keras integration actually
works.
Here is a convolutional
network running
on standard Keras model.
It runs on CPUs or GPUs.
Let's convert it to run on TPUs.
OK, done.
I didn't change anything.
You write your model
exactly as you did before.
The only thing you
have to do is you
pass your existing
standard Keras model
to Keras support.tpu model.
And you pass in a
couple of extra things
like your distribution
strategy and the cloud
TPU you want to run on.
This will return to you
a TPU-ified Keras model.
After that, that's it.
Use it just like a
standard Keras model.
Passing in num.py data,
passing a data set,
do whatever you want with it.
Call fit, call fit generator.
Call evaluate.
Use it just like a
standard Keras model.
We're really excited
about the flexibility
that this sort of an
API and Keras brings.
Keras is a really
great API and framework
from machine learning.
A lot of people really like it.
Now it's even easier than ever
before to go to TPU hardware.
So now that we have
multiple APIs, well,
how do you choose which one?
If you already have a model
that's using estimators,
definitely migrate
just to TPU estimator.
This will give you
production, great performance.
It's reliable, it's very
robust, it works very well.
If you have a lot
of Keras models,
definitely try out our new
experimental Keras integration.
This is a lot more
flexible, and people really
like it who have
tried it so far.
But if you haven't
started, I want
to give you a bit of intuition.
If you're starting
something from scratch,
I want to give you
a bit of intuition
as to which API
you should choose.
One thing to note though.
The same team is developing
both TPU estimator and Keras.
And so although there are
current advantages to one
versus the other, expect
feature convergence over time.
For now though, TPU
estimator scales
to whole pods with
zero code changes.
It's super fast, has
all the performance
optimizations in it.
Keras, by contrast, is a little
bit more flexible and easy
to use.
Error messages are often
a little bit easier
to understand.
It supports non-static
shapes through a bunch
of dynamic recompilation
underneath the hood for you.
So we're really excited
about both these two APIs.
If you want more
flexibility, go with Keras.
If you're in production,
you want peak performance,
go with TPU estimator.
Now we've gone
through the mechanics
of how do you actually program
these cloud TPU devices.
But as we've migrated a
huge number of customers
from other hardware
platforms to TPUs,
and we've done this both
internally at Google
and externally as
part of Google Cloud,
we've gleaned a number of
best practices and tips.
So I'd like to walk you
through a few of them today.
Far and away the best advice we
can give you is, if possible,
start with a reference model.
These are well-tuned,
they're reasonably clean,
they are tested to
converge reliably.
So our RestNet-50
implementation,
if you train it on
ImageNet, you're
going to get 76.2% top-1
accuracy every single time.
These are high quality both
in the machine learning
and in the performance.
But if you can't, and
you have an existing code
base that you've invested in
for your machine learning model,
we have a workflow that
often works pretty well.
Step one is on your existing
hardware port to estimators.
This often results in
a bunch of code getting
deleted that you
sort of manually
were doing, like checkpoints
and things like that.
And then at this
step, once you've
completed your
port to estimator,
be sure to verify convergence.
This is often a mistake
that people skip.
Once you're sure that your
model is working exactly
as you expect, then do
the mechanical change
from estimator to TPU estimator.
Start with use TPU as
false, and make sure
that the mechanical
changes work just fine.
And after that, turn on TPUs
and you're off to the races.
And finally, be sure to
optimize performance.
You won't see the full
benefit of cloud TPUs
if you ensure they're not being
bottle-necked by your CPU input
pipeline.
Now this is a very common
workflow migrating existing
models to TPU hardware,
but we've actually
seen a lot of people just
start on cloud TPUs natively.
There are a number of really
compelling advantages for that.
In addition to being cheaper,
most importantly, they're fast.
And so you can iterate
much more quickly
than you can on any other
hardware platform that we see.
So if you want to bring up a
brand new model from scratch
and you're not starting from
one of our existing models,
be sure to iterate
very regularly.
As you-- it's much easier to
debug a few lines of code delta
than it is a thousand-line
model function with a very
sophisticated network.
If you're trying to figure
out your shape inference,
you need static shapes.
And shape inference isn't
working right, much easier
to figure that out if you've
just changed a couple of lines
than if you have to hunt through
a thousand-line model function.
So iterate regularly.
As a bonus tip, make sure to
optimize your input pipeline
performance early.
This just is gas on
the iteration speed,
and just helps you go
a whole lot faster.
Once you've got a basic
thing working, usually
on a single cloud TPU
vise, take advantage
of what is the magic of
TPUs, which is you can scale.
Scale these out to whole fleets
to run hyper parameter searches
in parallel, or scale up
to train your models super,
super fast.
Get results, turnaround,
optimize your model,
and develop your system.
So there are some of the
high-level best practices.
Let's dig down again
to the nitty gritty.
When you're developing models
on cloud TPUs, some of us
aren't perfect coders.
We end up putting
bugs in our systems.
And so I want to walk you
through some common errors
that people sometimes
stumble upon
so that you have an
intuition for what's going on
and how to solve these
common issues that come up.
The first one is
unimplemented error.
This file scheme local
was not implemented.
It tells you the file
that it's trying to do,
and you'll grep
through your code,
and you're like nowhere
do I reference slash 10.
What the heck's going on?
This is very common, because
estimators and therefore
TPU estimator, handles
software failures.
It handles hardware failures.
It handles other
problems in your system.
And so as a result, it
requires a checkpoint directory
so it can save and
restore training progress.
And if you don't provide
at a checkpoint directory,
it will helpfully create
one for you on slash 10.
Now when you try and
run this on a cloud TPU,
the cloud TPU is a
totally different device.
It cannot read or write to
slash temp on your GCVM.
This will totally break all
the security abstractions,
like it just doesn't work.
And so what's happening
here is that it's
trying to do just that.
So the solution is to whenever
you're running a TPU estimator
model on a cloud TPU, be sure
to specify the model directory.
That's where your
checkpoints get saved to
and they get restored from.
You need to set the
checkpoint directory
to be someplace on
a shared file system
that both the cloud TPU
and your Python process
can read and write to.
This is often GCS,
Google Cloud Storage.
Another common error
message is the following.
You get this NotFoundError:
No register 'Where'
OpKernel for XLA_TPU_JIT.
So what's going on here?
Well, remember that
TensorFlow graph
gets converted into an XLA
graph, which then gets compiled
and runs on the TPU device.
And what's happening is we don't
have a CF to XLA kernel for the
where op, OK?
And so what you
need to do is see
if you can restructure your
program, your TensorFlow graph,
to not use these ops
that we don't have
a translation for into XLA.
Alternatively, you
could implement the T F
to XLA kernel, because all
these are fully open sourced.
You can implement your
own, or file a bug
and we'll see if we
can prioritize getting
those OpKernels implemented.
OK, another common error
message that people might see
is the following.
NotFoundError: No
registered 'Cast' OpKernel
for XLA_TPU_GIT.
Aha, we'll we've seen
this one before, right?
Well as it turns out,
it's a little subtle.
The final parenthetical
is the key difference.
The OpKernel was found.
So there is a TF
to XLA OpKernel,
but the attributes didn't match.
So let's dig into what
are the attributes.
We've got our destination
type of DT int16.
Our source type, DT
float, and a device.
Now the device is fine.
The issue is actually DT int16.
TPUs don't support int16.
They only support float32 or
DT float, int32, et cetera.
So the solution
here is to, instead
of trying to cast to
int16, leave it as float,
or cast to int32.
If you want to see what
ops a priori, before you
get these error messages, if you
want to see what ops are likely
compatible with TPUs or not,
we have this really cool TPU
compatibility checker.
And the tools page
documents really clearly
how you can use it.
Now one thing to note.
We're constantly adding
new kernel implementations
and supporting new
data types, et cetera.
And so the source
of truth is often
the compiler and the TensorFlow
version you're actually using.
So be aware that there is
some delta between what
the tool says and the reality.
The final error message that
people often stumble over
is the following.
NotFoundError: Op type
not registered 'PyFunc.'
Now remember, cloud TPUs are
this distributed computation
device.
Your Python runs on your
GCVM, but the cloud TPU
has no Python available
to it on the CPU.
It's just a C++ binary,
as it turns out.
And so you can't use
PyFuncs on your cloud TPU.
However, with a little
bit of cleverness,
you can use PyFuncs in
your input function,
like we are here, our
input pipeline task zero.
You can do that
with a technique I'm
going to show you in the
next section, which brings me
to feeding a TPU program.
So I want to take a step back
before we delve into this
and actually remark upon a trend
that is happening across TPUs.
In fact, if you look
at Nvidia's Volta GPUs,
they're phenomenal accelerators.
They're really fast.
And Nvidia's done a great
job working on them.
And if you try to run a
fast model on Nvidia Volta
GPUs, like RestNet-50,
on a GG x-1,
you'll find that the
local SSD can't keep up.
We've seen this in
TensorFlow as we benchmark
on a wide variety of
hardware platforms
that unless you have a
high-performance storage
system, your
accelerators are actually
going to sit idle waiting
for data to be fed in.
And in this case, just the
raw throughput of the SSD
can't keep up.
If you have the data in memory
on your RAMDisk you're fine.
But if it's on
the SSD and you've
got a cold RAMDisk or a cold
buffer cache, you're not.
And if you try and
optimize around this,
it can often be quite pricey.
So one company found
that the storage costs
alone on a non-GCP
platform was more
expensive than the entire cloud
TPU solution including storage,
including the cloud
TPUs themselves,
in this case it was
preemptible including the GCVMs
to drive it.
So the entire GC
solution was cheaper
than just storage on
this other platform.
The GPUs could be
completely free.
The compute could
be completely free.
The VMs, the compute, everything
could be completely free.
Just the storage alone
was more expensive.
And so to tell you
about how you can
feed fast accelerators, TPUs,
but also GPUs on Google Cloud
platform, this is available.
All these are available
in standard TensorFlow.
I want to walk you through
three ways that you can do this.
So the first and most common
way is Google Cloud Storage.
This is a distributed
file system
that is optimized for
both extreme scale
and shockingly low cost.
Whoops.
The next one that people often
do is use Compute Engine.
This allows you to stream
data from either local SSDs
or in-memory data structures.
This is where you
can use PyFuncs
to preprocess your data.
You can stream the data
from GCVMs into a cloud TPU.
And finally, I'm really
excited to announce a brand-new
integration coming in TensorFlow
1.10 over the next few weeks.
That is Cloud Bigtable.
Cloud Bigtable, for those
of you who are not familiar,
is a wide-row, structured
storage system.
Scales out horizontally,
and has amazing performance
both for low latency as
well as high throughput,
which is relatively unique
for a system of this caliber.
So to walk you through
what these all are like
and how to use them,
let's dig right in.
Cloud storage is definitely
the default choice.
It's a familiar abstraction.
Files on it should
be the file system.
People are-- easy, it's
very easy to work with.
Has very nice UIs
and integrations
with a wide variety
of different tools.
I have some tips
and tricks for you
to make sure you can get
the best performance out
of Google Cloud Storage.
The first one is make sure
you select regional storage,
so not multi-regional, not
near-line, not cold-line,
or else you're going
to get a nasty bill
at the end of the month,
because those end up
being far more expensive for use
with high-performance compute
devices like cloud TPUs.
Additionally, make
sure that your data
is in the exact same region
as your accelerators, US
central one or Europe
west four, or in Taiwan.
Additionally, GCS is optimized
for high throughput but not
low latency.
And so in order to
work around, in order
to achieve high
performance, you need
to batch your data into
large often TF record files.
We've found that 100
megabytes to 200 megabytes
works very well to
allow-- it's a sort
of a sweet spot between
parallelism and throughput
of the files.
To handle all this complicated
data loading and parallelism
and software pipelining,
TF data makes it very easy.
So let's walk
through an example.
Here we are loading a
set of TF record files
in this case from a GCS path.
We're reading 32
files in parallel.
And after that,
we've constructed
a data set that we can
then preprocess or do
whatever we want.
This works, of course,
for cloud TPUs,
but GPUs on GC, et cetera.
That's it.
Just two lines of code.
It's pretty easy.
Next one I want to talk
about is Compute Engine VMs.
We have a few
different ways that you
can feed data into cloud
TPUs at high performance.
The first one is the
streaming files data set.
This is a software
pipeline data in feed
that you can read from
local disk, often local SSD,
because that's faster
than persistent disk SSD.
But you can feed from both.
With streaming files,
you can actually
use arbitrary
Python to preprocess
the data using
PyFuncs or otherwise
to stream it into a cloud TPU.
Now often we've found if
you do try and use PyFuncs,
that will be a
performance bottleneck.
But for certain
models, this absolutely
makes a lot of sense.
It's also great as
an experimentation
or getting started tool.
Additionally, you have a second
method, which is this RPC op.
You can actually load data
from any arbitrary GRPC server
as long as you implement
a small GRPC interface.
This works really well when data
is being generated on the fly,
especially if data is stored
in memory, for example,
in reinforcement learning
type style workloads.
So to give you an illustration
of what's going on,
you have a Compute
Engine VM, and you're
passing the streaming
files data set from the VM,
streaming the data from
the VM into the cloud TPU.
Now TensorFlow is designed as
a distributed execution engine.
So you can actually stream
data from multiple GCVMs
into one cloud TPU.
Or of course, you can use the
RPC op for one or more GCVMs.
To take a look at some code to
see how you'd actually do this,
here's an example of the
streaming files data set.
We're reading from a
local path on disk.
In this case, we're
doing TF records.
But if you wanted to do more
complicated preprocessing,
you can pass in a
few extra arguments
and you're off to the races.
One thing to note.
You do have to configure
your TPU cluster resolver
a little bit
differently in order
to ensure that the cloud TPU
knows where to find your GCVM
to pull the data from.
And finally, I'd like to talk
a few minutes about Cloud
Bigtable.
In some benchmarks,
Cloud Bigtable
has been shown to be over ten
times faster than Cloud Google
Storage.
So it's this amazing
performance system.
And because it's a database,
high-scale database,
you can have a
flexible schema and you
can query your data in a
variety of different patterns.
So it's really valuable for
experimentation or other sorts
of workloads.
Additionally, if you're
generating your data
on the fly, from
say multiple worker
VMs you're doing like self-play
in a reinforcement learning
algorithm, you can stream
the data into Bigtable
and you don't have to create
your own batch record files
or anything like that.
Bigtable handles all of
that for you automatically.
I have a sample script
available on GitHub
for how to load TF
records into Bigtable,
but it's designed to
be easily flexible
and rewritten to stream
data of whatever format
you want into Bigtable.
Getting data out of Bigtable is
also really easy with TF data.
You create a Bigtable
client, you open the table,
and then you can scan rows
either by range or by prefix,
specifying whatever
column families
and columns you want out.
This gives you a data set that
you can use just like normal.
So with TF data, it's very
flexible and very easy
to switch between all
these different data
sources while maintaining
your preprocessing operations,
et cetera, lower down
in your input function.
Now that we have choices,
well how do you choose?
This walks through
sort of the pricing
of these different
storage solutions.
So Google Cloud Storage is
$0.02 per gigabyte per month
and is the cheapest.
The other storage systems have
different prices as listed.
Google Cloud Storage, you
don't pay unless you're
pulling data out of it.
So the hourly overheads are
zero, which is really nice.
On the second half of
the slide of this table,
I walk through sort of
the pricing example.
If you have a one
terabyte training data set
and you train on
it 10 hours, here's
your costs for just the storage
and for everything all-in,
whether you're using
a standard cloud
TPU or a preemptible cloud TPU.
So that's an overview of
our three main areas, what's
going on underneath the
hood of a cloud CPU,
how to program a cloud
TPU using our new APIs,
and finally, how to feed data.
But I want to take this all back
to really the whole purpose,
which is you.
We've talked about how to use
cloud TPUs on Compute Engine,
but you can also use it on Cloud
ML engine or Kubernetes Engine.
Cloud ML Engine
makes it very, very
easy to switch between
CPUs, GPUs, or TPUs.
Just change one flag for your
model and resubmit your job.
Kubernetes has this
new integration
where you can request a
cloud TPU to be provisioned
and de-provisioned for
you as part of your pods
when your pods get
launched and deleted
on the Kubernetes cluster.
So these higher-level
APIs are really nice.
They handle a lot
of the convenience.
You don't have to worry about
network ranges, et cetera.
So really excited
to have all three
of these different
engines available to you
for your workloads for
whatever your style of work is.
But I want to take a step
back and realize, well,
what are TPUs really.
And I want to sort of take
a different interpretation
of things.
This is a plot that shows
the performance of a model
as it scales across a
single cloud TPU device
up to a whole second-generation
cloud TPU pod of 64 devices.
On the dotted line
is perfect scaling,
and the blue line is the
observed performance.
Now this is a cool
chart that shows
like yes, wahoo, our custom
mesh network is super fast.
But what this means for you
is that you write your model
on a single cloud TPU device.
And with zero code
changes, you scale it up
to a whole cloud TPU pod.
And you get your answers
linearly times faster
in many cases.
This means that TPUs
are like a time machine.
Instead of having to
wait days or weeks,
you can iterate in
hours or even faster.
And this just supercharges
both ML research as well as
ML product development.
We're bringing all
this technology to you
as we optimize from our
storage systems, our compute,
our network, and
our TPU devices.
We're bringing all this
great technology to you.
The sky's the limit.
Develop your
applications ethically.
Conduct your
research responsibly.
But I'm super excited to
see what you all will build.
Thank you very much
for your time today.
[APPLAUSE]
A few extra sessions--
third time's a charm.
There's a few extra sessions
available that you cannot see,
there we go, that are
also relevant to TPUs
if you're interested.
And I'm happy to
take questions over
off to the side, because
I am way out of time.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]